my good friend andy richter is with us
happy inauguration day andy the
inauguration day it is a happy day it
feels good doesn't it
yeah i thought it was a very lovely
ceremony
yeah i thought i really loved biden's
speech i thought he gave an amazing
inauguration speech yeah and uh
mike pence had to confront lady gaga
well
those two have i didn't see that moment
actually did they
was it was it awkward oh i don't i don't
know i just i imagine at some point he
was like
ms gaga hello thank you
[Laughter]
miss gaga i have heard of your work yeah
i'm a fan and on the car ride out to the
airport his wife was probably like
i saw you talking to that lady gaga
keep it in your pants next time pence
sorry mother
[Laughter]
i i just i thought it was uh absolutely
lovely you know
it was uh it was a wonderful ceremony
yeah um
i like when garth brooks came out it
looked like he was walking into a saloon
in western you know when he came walking
out and he had the hat and the boots and
it really did look like he had just i
wanted to see him get on a horse
and ride off afterwards well yeah but
also too he like hugged and kissed
everybody like everyone else is being
careful and not
not garth yeah you know i'm sure they've
all been
tested and they were all boiled
everybody
all the performers and everyone on that
stage was boiled for 20 minutes yeah
yeah
in hot liquid so it was a very safe
inaugural yeah
but uh wow just such a historic day
um and of course the inauguration was
the big news
all the cable networks uh covered it
here's a clip of cnn's coverage
here is uh msnbc during biden's speech
and then here's how fox news covered it
because you're stirring you want to whip
the air
apparently their plan is to just go with
an omelette marathon for the next
four years it's going to be a four-year
omelette marathon
that's terrible for your heart
really maybe yeah i think it should yeah
most doctors would say a two-year
omelette marathon
is the recommended daily allowance yes